[موسيقى]
شركه
تيتان البرتغالي الاصيل الذي وصلت شهرته
الى جميع انحاء العالم ينحدر من السلاله
الايبيريه وتاريخه يصل الى 300 عام عمل
المربون على تحسين نسله باستمرار لاسيما
الحجم وتنوع الالوان
[موسيقى]
فيديو ميركاتش تيرن انك
ميريكان
كيفيه مساله
[موسيقى]
وبحسب البرتغاليين هو حصان ذكي سهل
للانقياد ويتعلم بسهوله ولديه شخصيه جيده
وهو بالنسبه لهم واحد من افضل سلالات
الخيول لكن على ملاك المزارع التكيف مع
متطلبات السوق وفي الوقت نفسه الحفاظ على
نقاء السلاله اختبار
[موسيقى]
في العديد من قرى البرتغال وبلدتها يتم
الاحتفال بالخيول علاقه خاصه تربط السكان
بهذا الحيوان الذي اصبح مع الوقت رفيقا
يوميا لهم وتقام له المعارض والمهرجانات
[موسيقى]
عشق جاري والصغار
في بدايه اعمارهم نشاوا على اقامه صداقه
فريده مع الحصان منذ نعومه اطفالهم
شاركونا اراءكم ما هي سلاله الخيل التي
ترغبون في اقتناءها يوما ما